so I watched your documentary I loved it
not just a girl she was the first person
to break that door open and go across
the music genres you talked a lot about
Dolly Parton and how she was an
inspiration to you
how does it feel that knowing that you
are someone else's Dolly Parton now you
are on that level I would never see
myself as Dolly Parton
I just she's just so iconic to me and
legendary and uh so influential she's
just brilliant but I do understand that
kids or that who were kids
20 30 years ago growing up to my music
now are adults some of them
are icons in their own rights
voicing my inspiration in their own work
so it's awesome
I just love that it's me it's humbling
because they're so amazing and I admire
them
it motivates me it's very motivational
[Music]